today the Trump administration announced
its putting an end to daca President
Obama's controversial program that bars
the federal government from deporting
illegal immigrants brought to the United
States as children under the president
Trump's plan daca will begin phasing out
six months from now and in the meantime
the president is urging Congress to act
on the issue I have a great heart for
these folks we're talking about a great
love for them and people think in terms
of children but they're really young
adults I have a love for these people
and hopefully now Congress will be able
to help them and do it properly and I
can tell you and speaking to members of
Congress they want to be able to do
something and do it right and really we
have no choice we have to be able to do
something and I think it's going to work
out very well and long term it's going
to be the right solution and within the
last half-hour president Trump tweeted
out quote Congress now has six months to
legalize daca something the Obama
administration was unable to do if they
can't I will revisit this issue unquote
joining us now with details his chief
national correspondent edy Henry head
Danish shout out to Gutfeld of course
especially after Labor Day but well you
see the president doing there is
throwing down the gauntlet and saying
Congress has to do its job he's facing
political mine fields from the left to
the right basically some Republicans
warning that the president can lose
control Republican control of Congress
if this issue is not handled well but
people inside the White House tell me
they're still hopeful they can get a
compromise where they show the president
is moving to the middle trying to be
humane towards the dreamers in exchange
wants Democrats to compromise as well
and get tough on illegal immigration
either a down payment on the wall or
other measures to go after illegal
immigration the attacks though fast and
furious from the left as I mentioned you
see former President Barack Obama
they're breaking with recent tradition
of formers of not blasting the decisions
of the current occupant of the office
because he believes this is a matter of
conscience Obama declaring quote
ultimately this is about basic decency
this is about whether we are a people
who kick hopeful young strivers out of
america or whether we treat them the way
we'd want our own kids be treated it's
about who we are as a people and who we
want to be of course we should note the
former president did not codify this
into law when he had a chance to do that
one of the many problems he handed off
to President Trump so President Trump
now taking flak as well from the right
you have hardliners against illegal
immigration like Republican Steve King
of Iowa insisting the commander-in-chief
should have simply ended daca altogether
not giving Congress a six-month window
to try and codify it into law king
saying the president made quote caused a
great big civil war among the
Republicans but Jeff Sessions the
Attorney General who took the lead on
the issue today insisted compromise can
be found watch we are people of
compassion and we are people of law but
there is nothing compassionate about the
failure to enforce immigration laws and
even Senator Lindsey Graham a Republican
who is not a reliable supporter of this
president came out today and said the
Republican there are Republicans like
him on the hill who believe the
president stepped up here put the issue
right where it belongs on Capitol Hill
and here is the key in fact President
Obama said much the same in June of 2012
when he issued this executive order on
daca he said look this is an executive
action in the middle of an election year
2012 he called it quote a temporary
stopgap measure
clearly President Obama at that time was
saying he wanted to move forward but
eventually Congress would have to try
and codify this into law Dana all right
and Henry thank you so much Greg let's
start with you because there's been a
lot of hysteria which we're going to
talk about in the B block but maybe by
the end when President Trump tweets that
tonight we realize that he just wants to
get to the status quo and have Congress
codify it how do
did I miss something here I don't
understand what this what where the
panic is coming from all Donald Trump is
doing is moving like a box from one room
to the other it's like you know when
somebody leaves you know a box of
trophies and diplomas in the living room
you go no that's in the den Jackie he's
gone like this thing the Dahmer of that
debt President Obama left there another
stink bomb that he leaves by the way
President Obama is really good at this
into turning people
to reverse Santa's he gives something
away knowing that nobody wants to be a
reverse Santa so he's making Donald
Trump fix his mess all Donald Trump is
saying this has to be fixed this is
something that you left you yourself
said it was a makeshift stopgap to help
non-citizens now I got to clean up this
mess I just want it done that's all he's
doing it's just it's amazing that how
that how the good guy in this is the guy
who created this faulty band-aid and the
bad guy is the one who's looking out for
American interests in seeking to fix
this band-aid it should be the answer
that is interesting and Thank You Dana
well you know I've been gone morbid
Henry do you want yes I want four more
minutes of it all right well let's try
to get that for you in the next block
but first we must go to Jesse waters for
his thoughts on this do you think
Congress can get it done in six months
in six months no in six years no I don't
trust Congress to do anything off of
Greg's analogy reverse Santa this is
kind of like President Obama for
Christmas gives you a stolen car and
then you're riding around the stolen car
you're real happy about if you're kind
of looking over your shoulder and all of
a sudden sheriff Trump comes along and
seizes the hot car back and says you
know what listen we're not going to
arrest you but we're going to drive you
to the dealership we're going to get you
some good numbers on a new lease there
you go but everyone's mad at Trump it
doesn't make any sense I think this is a
law-and-order play done in a caring way
remember Obama said this is
unconstitution then two years later
turns it around did it anyway and it
caused this mad rush of people from
Central America bringing their kids
cause a humanitarian crisis at the
border Congress makes immigration law
the executive doesn't so all of these
states now sue the executive Trump says
you know what I want to defend this
illegal act let's kick it to Congress
they'll hammer out a play for this as
long as these people are protected
that's fine now he's the bad guy doesn't
make any sense Kennedy won talking about
the states that were suing one of the
things that there's been some commentary
about is that President Trump could have
done what President Obama did on gay
marriage so wait for this lawsuits to
come in take it to the Supreme Court and
then all of a sudden announce we're not
going to defend that so basically making
it defacto law no but he shifts it to
Congress and the difference between
same-sex marriage and immigration is
Congress has an obligation a moral
obligation to hammer out the immigration
policy in this country and what the
president did President Obama did was it
was very cool he talks about cruelty and
he talks about morality
he knows how easy it is to undo an
executive order he knows how easy it is
to unright a memo like that but he was
toying with 800,000 lives
800,000 people who were brought here
essentially against their will
most of them a vast majority work they
want to be Americans they've done
nothing wrong if that were so important
so critically important and I argue that
our immigration policy is such a mess
that it is
then the president back in 2009 had the
moral obligation to take care of
immigration instead of screwing up the
health care system like he did with the
implicit failure that is Obamacare well
to that paurav oh darling there is a
compassionate argument to be made about
the people who the 800,000 who might not
see it the way that we do and from a
perspective of just looking at this
logically right so if you are if you are
worried and you have anxiety that you
might have to you know start packing
things up you don't know where you might
go there is something to be said about
that I think they could have done that a
little bit in a nicer way and I'm not
meaning that I think the president
Trump's announced I think that Jeff
Sessions announcement should have been
immediately followed by the speech by
the President or like a statement in the
Rose Garden or something that would ease
attentions if that was his intent
ultimately the tweet tonight saying I
want them to get to this so that I can
sign it that probably would have
basically turned the temperature down
today look you're trying to dress up
what was a brutal mean act I mean
there's 70 percent of the American
people this is not even a political
divide thing that this program should
remain in place 70 percent that's that's
on the way you'd be able to pass
Congress absolutely but remember
President Obama got it through the house
it got held up in the Senate Republican
opposition to the overall immigration
reform in this country and we know that
story going back to the Bush
administration to your years we know
that the right wing just stopped
immigration let me finish up so by doing
that to that my feeling is very strongly
that what you're talking about here is
playing politics with young people with
people
lives who did that as they are going to
have a man named Obama anxiety about
where they stand and you are potentially
breaking up families by saying the kids
would have to go and these are people
who have served in our military these
are people who are in school these are
people who for the I think it's
overwhelming have no criminal record so
what you're talking about is the man
thing the president Crump saying oh this
is about law and order oh my gosh I must
have forgotten about Joe Arpaio Law &
Order only goes one way it goes against
little kids but it's okay for Joe Arpaio
house up beating and breaking though I
mean again I don't know how is this unit
you said it was mean in the beginning me
Lane why I told I said it was me no you
didn't more caring I say no it's been
another that society nothing happening
it's going to create as I gotta do but
it hasn't happened anxiety it has in
hand right now and go
he's kicking oh he's kicking it back to
Congress so it will be ratified know
that Congress can't even get immigration
reform here you want that occur to you
you wanna hear the kicker to you
President Trump will not say tonight
that he would support this bill separate
and apart from the larger immigration
reform which is as you address
what's wrong with his tweet tonight no I
do not he is not said I will support
this as a separate bill II said if
Congress doesn't get their act together
I'll handle it well here what are you
going to hurt that hard to watch oh so
what's he going to a minute ago you said
this was a ball about kicking it into
Congress's court and I said but and you
said that as well but the fact is so
he's going to now take it back and say
I'm going to do say what is he going to
do beyond what Brennan he will do it
through exist why does everybody's going
to try to get it done maybe through a
path wider than a just weight a
merit-based system if they get one okay
Oh better we can get it done one to your
point
why doesn't he wait my question is and
we're going to talk about North Korea
because there's a lot to talk about
with everything going on in North Korea
with with Congress you know as seeming
inability to pass legislation that
should be layups for the Republican
Party how on earth are they going to
tackle all of this stuff well this is my
point I don't see that they're they have
any real prospects of getting this done
within six months or a Republicans in
Congress pass but what am the
be quicker than they can pass tax cuts
so Paul Ryan
well they can appeal Obamacare but now
they have their outside I think he would
have sawn it if there it came into a
large iron bill that is that's why the
politics of tricky can I go back to
something cuz I do want to but this is
just to reiterate your point your point
is Jesse's just well I'd let you finish
earlier going I think that it's not fair
to say that it's the right that has
played politics with immigration only it
has been both parties for sure and then
take you back to 2007 when President
Bush gave the first-ever domestic policy
address from The Oval Office on
immigration reform they're very close to
getting it done yes the room on the
right were frustrated but the the votes
were there but guess who pulled it back
Reid and Barack Obama why because Barack
Obama wanted to run on the issue in 2000
I don't believe that you know who you
know who pulled it back it was an end
President Bush President Bush spoke to
this it was right-wing talk radio that
built a wall what right way to talk
radio is not constitutionally bound oh
good okay the base today our star dish
okay it we saw that it didn't go through
under President Bush I understand that
it's interestingly always a bipartisan
effort I mean it always is whenever it
makes its way through so if it were so
critically important and if you needed
these voters so badly to bolster the
Democratic Party if these people were an
absolute gimme to make sure the
Democrats had the presidency from
President Obama to Eternity why wasn't
that at the top of your agenda why why
did you give America a horrible horrible
awful meant to fail health counseling
because I know that President Bush in
his meeting with Obama in that
transition period suggested to him to do
immigration before he did health care it
was obviously important to President
Bush who was it across borders but but
as I recall at the start of it was
dealing with the economic crisis and you
don't get immigrant I'm so you'll get
health care reform until like 2010 so
initially we're dealing with all the
economic issues then we come to health
care and he had then were Democratic
majorities by 2012 that's dynamic issues
you get a linebacker
well dr. Craig goes back to the original
thing President Obama started the
fire and tonight he's tackling the fire
department because he the reason why you
have Donald Trump is because of
President Obama he created the antidote
to himself by flouting the laws and
three different you considered so many
examples of this and this is one of them
he floated the laws and now we're
dealing with it and we're destroying the
prize yet another president is using
executive order exactly what he thought
II did so easily like an emperor who I
declare you galvanized her stay he's
galvanized perception of national
neglect that led you to Trump if he had
done this this wouldn't be a problem
then thank Jessie was talking about will
be the next big issue which is that if
the if the members of Congress are able
to get something passed and President
Trump signs it then who's gonna actually
be more mad well the base be frustrated
oh they won't be be but that's where I
think I think of President Trump he can
do anything right now right that's the
point think when it's not no longer
about ideology or any a capital in his
face yeah what if that wall is beautiful
doesn't matter what is the ace of it